[Music]
what's up guys michael here so a fun
thing happened this month lionsgate
approached us and asked if we could
spare a little of our philosophical
insight and matinee idol good looks to
help them celebrate the dvd and blu-ray
release of the hitman's wife's bodyguard
on august 17th and we thought that this
was the perfect opportunity to discuss
one of our favorite types of
entertainment escapist films featuring
truly all-in gonzo performances from
samuel l jackson salma hayek and ryan
reynolds the sequel to 2017's the
hitman's bodyguard is pure escapist fare
filled with big explosions
ridiculous gags people
[ __ ] insane and absurd plot twist
last time i saw something like this
bruce willis was drilling a hole in an
asteroid but is there something more
going on beneath the surface of this
brand of big budget crowd pleaser and
could it actually be way better at
exploring societal issues than you might
realize we think so and we'll explain
how in this wisecrack edition on how
popcorn films roast reality oh and fair
warning there will be spoilers
so
what is an escapist film anyway
according to 1980 new york times film
critic vincent canby an effectively
escapist film occupies the imagination
and transports us into other worlds we
escape through our commitment to the
film now based in part on their setting
in an other world escapist movies are
often dismissed as not having the same
cultural value as more realist serious
or message oriented films even the
people who enjoy them describe how you
can just turn your brain off and enjoy a
brief respite from reality and indeed
cinema has been a reliable coping
mechanism for american audiences for
almost a century with the great
depression producing some of the
greatest glitziest works of escapism
hollywood has ever seen because when
you're struggling through the middle of
the greatest economic catastrophe of all
time getting to spend a few hours
watching fred astaire and ginger rogers
glide across the silver screen could be
just enough to keep your soul intact
though the hitman's wife's bodyguard
doesn't feature any tap dancing it also
hit theaters during a bleak time you
know the literal once in a century we
hope plague and just like the razzle
dazzle classics the 1930s this film is
stacked full of gorgeous wildly
charismatic people who are at times also
mildly terrifying finally darius isn't
halting my dreams
if you don't help me i am gonna put my
strap on and i am gonna [ __ ] your dreams
until they wish they were your
nightmares anyway the film's action
scenes are also delightfully ridiculous
letting us know we're in an almost
looney tunes-esque reality where we
don't have to worry about all the
terrible things happening to our beloved
deadpool the point is to sit back and
laugh at how spectacularly violent it
all is especially when the characters
are going out of their way to make each
fight scene as silly as possible are you
using pepper spray
i'm on sabbatical
and uh trying to find my spiritual
awakening but beyond the over-the-top
action filthy one-liners and all-star
charisma is there something deeper to be
read into this movie we think so and
this is where the birmingham school of
film theory enters the conversation
founded by richard hogart at birmingham
center for cultural studies in 1964 the
school of thought basically argues that
there is genuine cultural value in every
form of art because it all reveals
something about the time it was made in
this is pretty much a theoretical
clapback to the commonly accepted
distinction amongst critics and scholars
which separated highbrow arts that was
intellectually nourishing and worthy of
analysis from lowbrow art that was just
good solid fun designed to keep regular
people from thinking too hard about the
world and spend their hard-earned money
of course the birmingham school for its
part argues that every piece of cultural
work will necessarily reflect some
aspects of the cultural unconscious of
its time that's simply because art's
never made in a vacuum but by and for
human beings with fears affections and
expectations that can't help but filter
into the final product essentially art
is the way society talks to itself about
itself and that's true even when that
art is saying fun and patently absurd
things like i'm going to be such a good
mother
i can't imagine
anyone gooder to see this theory in
action you just need to take a quick
flick through any of hollywood's most
popular films from past decades for
example sylvester stallone spent years
as the poster boy for muscle-headed
action flicks but the original rambo and
rocky at their heart were both simple
stories about regular guys who found
themselves under society's heel either
because they were traumatized military
vets or just blue-collar dudes with
limited economic opportunities the
former evokes the very real way veterans
are neglected by society while the
latter evokes the dedication and
strength of working-class people
struggling to get by in an unfair world
and even as their sequels got bigger
bloodier and a bit more brainless they
still retained a clear sense of the
nation's fears and preoccupations so if
cold war anxiety is in the air this
happens
and the same is true of pretty much
every successful blockbuster while
stallone was slugging it out with
soviet-engineered superman his fellow
muscleman arnold schwarzenegger was
tapping into our growing fears about the
rise of computer technology fast forward
a few decades and james cameron would
top the box office again with avatar
which battled in some rather
heavy-handed but undeniably prescient
messages about environmentalism
corporate greed and colonialism and we
will show the sky people
that they cannot take whatever they want
and that this big thing
this is orlando
and the hitman's wife's bodyguard is
absolutely no exception full of wild
antics and hollywood charm but still
clearly touching on some major real
world issues mistrust of institutions is
a big one the film's plot is set in
motion by the greek financial crisis
which was partially caused by the eu the
villain's dastardly plan is then to
cause more institutional failure by
shutting down the european electrical
grid and throughout the movie we see how
incapable institutions like interpol are
of keeping people safe in short every
institution we see is either corrupt or
incompetent so it falls to our three
unlikely heroes to save the day do not
[ __ ] this up oh we are definitely going
to [ __ ] this up this sort of rugged
individualism is a time-honored theme
for action movies the idea that the only
way to really get results is to forego
the bureaucracy and political infighting
of the powers that be and strike out on
your own relying solely upon your wits
fist and firearms to get the job done i
mean that's literally die hard to a t
i'm an [ __ ]
now you listen to me jerk off if you're
not part of the solution you're part of
the problem quit being part of the
[ __ ] problem and put the other guy
back on and the hitman's wife's
bodyguard reaffirms this theme in a
really comprehensive way morgan
freeman's character michael bryce senior
is a picture of conventional
institutionalized success with all the
awards trophies and commemorative
plaques from his days as a world-class
bodyguard to prove it but even though he
is the embodiment of how the system is
supposed to work and even though he is
also michael's stepfather he ultimately
turns out to be just as morally bankrupt
as every other member of the
establishment and ultimately a not so
great dad you aren't the dumbest mother
i have ever met
wow that uh i handle aristotle's
security detail while he's in italy you
[ __ ]
you you work for the bad guys a triple a
puts his clients ahead of god family and
certainly a painted way such as yourself
it's worth noting that here one of
organized society's most sacred
institutions the family also fails and
it's no coincidence that our three
unlikely heroes legally have coercively
form a family unit at the end of the
film my baby could carracha
you just signed the adoption papers but
beyond broken families even interpol
agents like frank grillo's character
learn that they can't get things done
working within the system forcing him to
call upon two known criminals and one
disgraced bodyguard to do the job
instead and the fact that they are
ultimately able to succeed where
everyone else fails underlines the idea
that sometimes if you want a job done
you can't really rely on institutional
protocol you have to do it yourself let
me do what we do in boston okay
we work with the bad guys to get the
worst guys but what happens when we take
popcorn friendly fair more seriously
some pretty interesting things see the
birmingham school of film theory was
revolutionary in this way and arguably
it offers a more productive way of
looking at the world than its
predecessors by acknowledging that even
cultural products which seem firmly
rooted in unreality can tell us
something important about ourselves and
like michael we're all just striving for
a better sense of who we are right hey
there future michael it's today michael
i'm not great at first impressions i
just want to say that i think you'd be
proud to know that i graduated therapy
what's more films like the hitman's
wife's bodyguard can help us to deal
with problems in the real world via the
catharsis of escape we weren't ready to
talk about the serious societal neglect
of vietnam veterans returning from war
so we talked about rambo instead it's
over johnny
it's over nothing is over
nothing
you just don't turn it off
it wasn't my war
you asked me i didn't ask you
and i did what i had to do to win we
weren't and apparently still aren't
ready to talk about colonialism and its
modern day legacy so we talked about the
movie black panther i observed for as
long as i could
that leaders have been assassinated
communities flooded with drugs and
weapons they are overly policed and
incarcerated these movies can create a
separate world for us to escape to
allowing us to view contemporary issues
from a slightly more comfortable and
less painful vantage point similarly we
might not want to spend one of our
precious summer nights watching a darkly
realistic movie about the economic
collapse of greece or the failure of the
institutions we trust to keep us safe
because without wanting to be callous
it's a huge bummer and we're already
dealing with enough so the hitman's
wife's bodyguard takes those issues and
works them into a wacky action-packed
story full of hilarious beautiful people
and that lets us take them in
cathartically while still enjoying a
good old-fashioned night at the movies
this catharsis occurs when these films
invoke real world problems and offer
some amount of resolution for them or at
least a victorious outcome in the face
of them rocky balboa can't end the cold
war nor the prejudices and anxiety it
fueled nor the massive geopolitical
fallout it left in its wake but our guy
can offer a clear heartwarming on-screen
conclusion to this violent dysfunction
what i'm
trying to say is
that if i can change and you can change
everybody should change
similarly black panther doesn't pretend
to offer a solution for racism and
colonialism but it does offer a vision
of a world in which the dispersal of
guns germs and steel wasn't quite so
unequal a world where an african utopia
can flourish and during a mid-credits
scene it also provides us with the
inspiring image of what that could mean
for the real world i am the sovereign
ruler of the nation of wakanda
and for the first time in our history
we will be sharing our knowledge and
resources with the outside world there
is an immense amount of catharsis to be
found in this kind of resolution giving
us the chance to engage with serious
issues in a slightly less serious more
optimistic way there may be no clear-cut
solution for the issues posed by
political corruption institutional
failure and broken economic systems but
we can gladly watch ryan reynolds samuel
l jackson and selma hayek succeed in the
face of these problems via elaborate
schemes half-baked ideas and a ton of
firepower so what do you guys think are
movies like the hitman's wife's
bodyguard just a straightforward good
time or can they reveal something more
about us and the society we live in
let us know what you think in the
comments be sure to catch the movie when
it lands on dvd 4k hd and blu-ray on
august 17th thanks as always to our
patrons for all your support
batter that subscribe button like you're
driving a boat into a barrel of
explosives and don't forget to ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
you